TO 300 IN NEW YORK CITY.
HE’S DEALT WITH SIMILAR
SITUATIONS, FORMER NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR RUDY GIULIANI IS WITH US.
YOU’VE BEEN TELLING THESE PEOPLE
HOW TO DO THEIR JOB.
IT’S NOT LIKE YOU DON’T HAVE
EXPERIENCE.
YOU HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS
PRETTY MUCH THE WHOLE TIME YOU
WERE A MAYOR AND YOU DID IT
SUCCESSFULLY.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT WOULD
LISTEN, AND CAN YOU PLEASE
EXPLAIN WHY THERE NOW -- AS
DE BLASIO AND CUOMO FIGHT
AMONGST THEMSELVES AND THEY
DON’T ASK FOR THE NATIONAL GUARD
THAT IT IS THEIR JOB TO ASK FOR,
THAT THE PRESIDENT THEN MIGHT
HAVE TO INVOKE AN 1807 LAW TO
BYPASS THEM AND USURP THE POWER
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT DOING THEIR
JOB.
>> THE de BLASIO-CUOMO PROBLEM
IS A SPECIAL PROBLEM.
THEY HATE EACH OTHER.
AND FRANKLY, de BLASIO IS
COMPLETELY INCOMPETENT.
AND THE GOVERNOR REALLY IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE SHOULD REPLACE HIM.
BECAUSE HE IS THE SOLE REASON
WHY THE NEW YORK CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT ISN’T ACTING AND IT
REALLY WASN’T FAIR OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO ATTACK THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
HE SHOULD HAVE ATTACKED
DE BLASIO.
HE KNOWS WHAT I KNOW.
SO I WILL TELL YOU THIS, SEAN,
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
THE BLASE OVER THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR OR FIVE NIGHTS CALLS
INDIVIDUAL POLICE CHIEFS AND
TELLS THEM NOT TO ENFORCE THE
LAW.
HE TELLS THEM NOT TO MAKE
ARRESTS.
HE GOES AROUND THE POLICE
COMMISSIONER AND DOES THAT.
IT’S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Sean: I WANT TO ASK YOU
THIS.
>> YOU DON’T WANT PEOPLE
STEALING AND NOT INTERRUPT THEM
UNLESS SOMEBODY IS HOLDING THEM
BACK.
THE PERSON HOLDING THEM BACK IS
MAYOR de BLASIO.
I KNOW THAT, CUOMO KNOWS THAT.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, CUOMO HAS
THE AUTHORITY -- SHE’S THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE.
WE HAVE COPS -- A BUFFALO YORK
TOO.
HE HAS THE AUTHORITY TO ASK THE
PRESIDENT.
>> NOT JUST ENFORCING THE LAW.
HE IS INTERFERING IN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
IN THE GOVERNOR SHOULD REMOVE
HIM.
IN THIS CITY, THIS SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN IN THE CITY.
WE HAVE A 35,000 PERSON POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
I HAD TEN TIMES WHERE THEY
ATTEMPTED TO DO THIS TO ME AND
THEY NEVER GOT BEYOND FIRST
BASE.
I HAD TO ARREST 700 PEOPLE ONCE
WITH CHIEF ESPOSITO.
WE DID IT.
THEY’VE ONLY ARRESTED A MEASLY
200 PEOPLE LAST NIGHT AND I RODE
UP AND DOWN MADISON AVENUE TODAY
AND I WENT ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
UNION SQUARE AND MY CITY -- IT’S
DISGRACEFUL.
THE MAN SHOULD HANG HIS HEAD IN
SHAME.
>> Sean: THE MAYOR -- THE
GOVERNOR --
>> HE’S A DISGRACE OF A MAYOR.
DEMOCRATIC MAYOR THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AREN’T MUCH BETTER.
THIS IS HAPPENING IN PROGRESSIVE
LIBERAL DEMOCRATIC CITIES
BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY FRIENDLY
TO CRIMINALS.
THEY LET THEM OUT OF JAIL.
THEY LET THEM OUT OF JAIL ON
RIDICULOUS BAIL LAWS.
IF THEY LET THEM OUT OF JAIL THE
MINUTE THEY HAVE CORONAVIRUS,
THEY LET THEM ALL OUT OF JAIL
AND THEY STOP RAPING PEOPLE LIKE
THEY DID IN NEW YORK.
>> MINNEAPOLIS LET THEM TAKE THE
POLICE PRECINCT TO ANTIFA AT ALL
THE NATIONAL GROUPS LIKE TO COME
IN AND PUSH THESE COPS AROUND
BECAUSE THEIR POLITICAL LEADERS
WILL NOT SUPPORT THEM.
THE COPS ARE BEING VICTIMIZED.
IT’S THE POLITICAL LEADERSHIP,
THE LEFT’S LEADERSHIP THAT IS
ALLOWING THIS TO HAPPEN IN 30 OR
40 AMERICAN CITIES THEY WERE ALL
DEMOCRATIC.
>> Sean: THE GOVERNOR --
MR. MAYOR, THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO CALL THE GUARD
HIMSELF.
THIS IS ALSO HAPPENING IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE.
HE HASN’T.
AT THIS GOVERNOR, YOU SEEM TO BE
GIVING HIM A PASS, HE’S THE ONE
THAT SIGNED THE BILL THAT
MANDATES THAT CRIMINALS HAVE NO
BAIL AT ALL SO THEY GET
INSTANTLY RELEASED AND CAN GO
RIGHT BACK TO WHERE THEY WERE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE ANARCHY
BECAUSE OF HIS LAW, WHY DOESN’T
HE CALL THE GUARD?
>> SITTING THERE IN ALBANY OR
WHEREVER HE IS, HE CAN REMOVE
de BLASIO AND HE COULD ORDER
THE POLICE COMMISSIONER OF
NEW YORK TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
AND THIS WILL END IN 24 HOURS.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE
NATIONAL GUARD?
>> THE NEW YORK CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS BIGGER, STRONGER,
BETTER, AND KNOWS WHAT IT’S
DOING MORE THAN THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
THE NATIONAL GUARD IS TRAINED TO
DEFEND US IN WAR.
THE NEW YORK CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS KEPT US OUT OF
RIOTS FOR 20 YEARS, 24 YEARS.
UNDER ME AND BLOOMBERG.
THEY JUST NEED A MAYOR.
>> Sean: I’VE GOT TO RUN.
>> STOP INTERFERING WITH THEM.
THEY’RE THE BEST LAW
ORGANIZATION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: I AGREE.
>> TWICE AS BIG AS THE FBI,
TWICE AS SKILLED AS THE FBI.
I RELY ON THEM TO DO MY --
>> Sean: I WILL ADD ONE THING.
I THINK HE SHOULD CALL IN THE
GUARD AND NUMBER TWO, HE NEEDS